why you just take their stuff Oh
Squidward you are everyone's favorite
octopus we know you aren't super happy
with your life working at the Krusty
Krab and it can't be easy living next to
SpongeBob and Patrick tell me what
you're doing here but we've seen you
smile a few times especially when you're
making music who can forget that episode
of band camp you are a talented clarinet
player and you're really smart you
deserve a chance to have a happy awesome
life Netflix and Nickelodeon announced
that they are partnering up to create a
SpongeBob SquarePants spin-off this show
is all about Squidward and it's not
exactly kid-friendly keep watching to
find out why the Netflix Nickelodeon
deal Netflix recently announced that
they are partnering up with Nickelodeon
to create some new shows many of these
shows will be reboots or spin-offs of
some totally nostalgic cartoons they
announced this right after Disney
launched its streaming service Disney
Plus and we have to admit it's quite the
comeback Disney Plus isn't just for kids
there are lots of Disney Channel movies
and shows from the 90s and early 2000s
that have millenials super excited
Netflix has been the most popular
streaming service for years they
realized they needed to do something to
keep up with their competition that's
why they are partnering up with
Nickelodeon Nickelodeon was responsible
for some of the best cartoons and kid
shows of all times unfortunately these
are hard to find online
Netflix will be working with Nickelodeon
to up their nostalgia factor they're
going to revamp old shows and create
spin-offs the biggest announcement was a
spinoff of Spongebob Squarepants a
[Applause]
history of spongebob spongebob
squarepants has been on the air for over
20 years it started in the summer of
1999 and became an overnight success the
show appealed to everyone from toddlers
to teenagers to adults the characters
are hilarious the storylines are
ridiculous but funny
and there's always just enough adult
humor to make parents laugh the creator
of Spongebob Squarepants was a marine
biologist and animator named Stephen
Hillenburg it was that moment where I
said maybe I should pursue this Stephen
passed away recently
but Nickelodeon has announced that
spongebob is getting another season in
2020 there's also a new movie coming out
in 2020 called sponge on the run the
success of the show isn't slowing down
anytime soon
why Squidward there are a ton of
characters that Netflix could make a
series about and they might do that in
the future a show about Patrick would be
popular with little kids because Patrick
is so silly sandy and mr. Krabs are
interesting and fun too but why do they
choose Squidward well that's easy
Squidward appeals to adults this is how
we note that the spin-off is not just
for kids Squidward is smart he has a
passion for music and he's a clarinet
champion the only times we see him truly
happy or when he's playing his clarinet
Squidward wants to come home from work
and live in peace but he's stuck in a
job he hates and he lives next to
annoying neighbors Squidward is totally
relatable to adults especially
Millennials who are known for working
outside of their desired fields that is
Squidward to a tee and Millennials have
been watching Squidward for years he's
got a huge fan base because he's so
relatable kids might have grown up
wanting to be like spongebob or Sandy
Cheeks but Squidward lives his life
always wanting to be better and that is
a universal truth for a lot of
Millennials Netflix is also banking on
the nostalgia factor plenty of people
still love spongebob even though they're
all grown-up nostalgia is a strong
emotion and people are always looking
forward to a blast from the past that's
why so many adults are excited about the
classic Disney content on Disney plus
there is guaranteed to be an audience
for all the Nickelodeon nostalgia
content on Netflix shows like Rocko's
Modern Life and invader zim are getting
reboots and we are totally pumped
what we know and what we don't we know
that the Squidward spin-off will be a
music based project that gives us hope
the Squidward starts to pursue his
clarinet career we also know that
Squidward's voice actor Rodger Bumpass
will be on the project that's great news
it just wouldn't be the same if it were
anyone else behind Squidward's grumpy
voice just do what you're doing school
Netflix has yet to reveal if this
project will come in the form of a
series or a movie or whether any of the
original characters will appear in the
spin-off it's possible but all the
actors will be busy with season 13 of
Spongebob are you a member of the things
family subscribe to our Channel and turn
on those posts notifications if you
haven't already if you're tuning in on
your mobile you can turn on
notifications in the YouTube settings
we'll be posting all about the new
Netflix Nickelodeon merge so subscribe
to get the latest news we are totally
excited to find out more about the
Squidward Show it's about time that
Squidward get some more screen time what
do you think the Squidward project will
be about let us know your theories in
the comments thanks for watching and be
sure to give this video a big thumbs up
we'll see you next time on the things